In conclusion I would like to say that
this has been a fantastic journey for us
and the wonderful team of people that
I've had in my lab. That's really, for me,
that's one of the best things to see.
These people do great work and they kind
of move on and set up their own labs and
flourish on their own. And in terms of
where we are now in terms of
understanding T-cell exhaustion and
understanding how to restore function
back and in terms of clinic, I think we
still have a ways to go, because
we would want to be able to get
much better response rates in the cancer
patients. Wwe want to be sure that there
is durability of the treatment that
they're getting. So here would require
greater understanding of the T-cell
exhaustion mechanisms. I would say maybe beyond PD-1.
You know, what can you do beyond PD-1, to take it to even to the
next stage. Combination therapies with either cytokines or other inhibitory
receptors, or with therapeutic
vaccinations are possibilities, but there
are other ways. Also there is a work that
we and others are doing looking at the
epigenetic landscape of exhausted cells
and could we change basically the insides.
The PD-1 actually is working at
the outside... well, inside can we change
the chromatin of the cell? Can we change
the epigenetic landscape of the cell?
So these are not easy to do, but there are
ways of doing this. There are enzymes
that methylate for example the DNA that
regulates gene expression. So, one we have
some preliminary data, that modulating
some of these methyl transferases will
change the function of the cells.
So there's very exciting and challenging
things that can be done to what I would
call changing the insides of the cell.
So the goal would be release the brake and
change the insides of the cell.
The next stage now is that why doesn't
everyone respond? Why is it only that the
rates are for melanoma,
the rates are actually quite high.
Melenoma responses are as high as 40
percent response rate to late stage melanoma.
But then you ask what about the other 50%.
Why don't they respond?
I think this is for us the
next challenge.
Are there other inhibitory receptors
that need to be identified and the
the right combination tried? Or do you need to provide some other kinds of stimulus?
Do you need to combine the PD-1
blockade with a therapeutic vaccine with
a vaccine against the cancer antigen?
So there's a very active area of research - many companies, many groups. And we're
also exploring these things and how can
you take it from being 30%, 40% out to
80% or 90%. That's a very, very high bar
but I think that's what the goal will be
for us and for all the other people
working in this in this area.
The other question is and for this we don't have
the answer yet. PD-1 has only gone into
cancer patients in the last few years,
and as I mentioned to you, in lung cancer
the response rates are between 20% in
that range for melanoma about 40-50 %
range, 40% range, but the question is...
so instead of their survival being
three months now, they're still alive two
years or three years. But the question is,
how long will be the durability of this
response? Will the cancer again come
back, if it come back what then?
Two issues that need to be assessed: how long will be the
durability of this effectiveness and
how can we get a response in the patients
who don't get the response. So I think
this science here is very exciting.
I would encourage any medical student who looks at this to go into the area of
cancer immunology - fascinating area where you can do basic science and also see
applications in the clinic very quickly.
And again I think the main message I
want to give you is do fundamental
discovery work and that will
result in something useful.